pour rappel le principe c'est très
simple je vais regarder derrière le
rideau et je veux faire de proposition
et vous allez devoir trouver qui se
cache derrière le rideau
attention je vais regarder qu'est ce que
je vais devoir vite
est ce que je viens de voir booba listo
à dire le sosie de booba en train de
manger a banni ce taux cette fois c'est
bel âge que j'ai vu date jus d'orange
ces dates jus qui boit un jus d'orange
pressé ou est ce que j'ai vu blackman m
baa va dire black m avec un personnage
amène m alors à votre oeil la grippe
même déjà c'est sûr que non parce que je
suis en train de lui parler actuellement
la promesse âge look black amy hennig il
regarde à la télé voilà donc c'est pas
blake est envoyée il est en pleine promo
et tout donc c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
l'état choo choo ou bouée dette vous
ferez litres alors il fera pas jouer la
chose à faire donc c'est le sosie de
booba oui je pense aussi que le sosie
booba ouais non pas des yeux vous pouvez
regarder toile et chaussées une banane
au parti qu'il se cache dans le rideau
bloqués
avec
m
mokhtar
[Applaudissements]
laquelle passe partout et l'arrivée
d'enfants boyard est bon avec talent et
vous emmerde pas les bras merci à 18
points vous asseoir et moi cela vous
inquiétez pas ce qu'il va avoir d'autres
surprises la maison sont qualifiés nous
balade ils m'ont plaqué caf un album
devenu si le monde oublie peut-être
d'amour c'est derrière on retrouve 2e
camille là bas je dis bonjour direct
james l'installer bloc m
mais blague cette serviette deuxième
villa bleue avec ça dit quoi direct
même avec un titre aussi incassable of
direct ah oui parce que on a une
ressource des scènes importantes partout
et black aimerait rouler magnifique
black m à son troisième album sort
demain
il était une fois oui il ya le titre
sale journée avec big three au lit
pendant un film érotique outre il s'est
excusé
sale journée il faut que tu as fait sale
journée merci le placard
l'acca l'acca tête avec nous
[Musique]
laquelle qui viendra nous voir version à
tous par vos posts et l'album de black
aimé ou fléchir il reste un petit peut
être nous black aime parce qu on l adore
ça fait je suis là avec plaisir
ça sent domaine sa soeur de demain
j'arrête pas lui aie aie aie attention
deuxième cabinet bluffe pas dans celle
qui se cache derrière le rideau
l'attenté est folle c'est vous la
deuxième personne qui se tâtent heures
l'heure le rideau la tête et est folle
folle à votre avis est ce que je vois m
pokora by jacob à dire pour cora
déguisant rabbi jacob
aulas ou bien j'aimerais bien est ce que
je vois la roue soprano s'agit de
soprano avec la coupe de la chanteuse
larusso cpa légumes frais à votre avis
tout est bien tout et vivait derrière le
rideau chez vous à votre ado non mais so
the sopranos sano super pote vraiment
recette a nommé slada logique c'est la
team là bas ils arrêtent de parler là
j'imagine aussi un alors non mais ça va
mais des fois où le web pourquoi moi je
dirais un vu qu'on connaît bien
mais son coup droit qui serait aussi
avec la coupe à la rousseau ouais
regardez ce qui s'est vu indiquer que
c'est ça ouais le bras on va regarder
tout de suite qu'ils s'attaquent ce sera
avec nous garder ouverts
[Applaudissements]
je sais pourquoi
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
si peu à côté de la caisse